joe montana here is uh joining us now
the four-time super bowl champ
uh hall of famer of course have you ever
worn your four super bowl rings at the
same time
i can't remember the last time i had one
on four no
but if you go to the super bowl and when
you're down there
or a hall of fame event you're not
wearing uh any of your rings no
uh no none of them not and um
not either the hall of fame one either
where is the nearest ocean
why do you like i treat them like
trophies
where are they right now in the safe
here in the house do you know the
combination
can you get them out for us
[Laughter]
uh it's good to talk to you and we were
talking about quarterbacks
and how you come into the league and it
used to be you had to adapt to the coach
and his style
his system if you were coming out of
notre dame now
would would they be adapting to your
style more so than the other way around
no i still think it happens that you you
walk into a system
sorry about that somebody is at the door
somebody's here early oh
that's my my daughter dropping our
granddaughter off so
we got her today do you have to go get
her no no my wife
oh jennifer's gonna grab her
i think you adapt to a system i mean you
have to learn
and then i mean if you start having
success i think the
if you look at guys like peyton who
eventually got to the point where he was
able to kind of control the offense and
do things he wanted to do and i think
that was when you look at tom i think
that's part of the reason he left was he
wanted to do things and
they wanted to do something different or
wouldn't allow them to do those things
and
a short time i had with him on at the
super bowl was
you know and they asked me what i want
to do and i tell them and then they do
something different or the opposite
so i think it was i think that's kind of
he was looking for a little bit more
control on that side but
i think that typically coming out of
college
sometimes they'll adapt a little bit of
what you do if it's totally different
from what
they do i mean if you look at the 49ers
and you go back and
well not just them but you go to cam
newton or
any of those guys that ran the read
option you know
everybody tried to do that at first and
then the defense figures out
you know how to defend it and the nfl
didn't take them long and so
you don't see that as much as you you
used to see
uh when it first became a fade a fad in
the
in um in college and then
the hard part is is you don't that style
doesn't really lend itself to learning
how to read a defense in most cases so
i think that's why a lot of those guys
struggle do you think that bill walsh
would
have let you run the offense from the
line of scrimmage
absolutely not
well at least you pause for effect there
joe yeah i was
trying to figure out another nice way to
say it i think that was
it um he you know
there's so many plays in his in our game
plans
and we would have 130 passes every week
in a game plan i mean we throw about
25 30 times at the most and we have 130
some play
passes only with a couple different
formations and
so it was it would have been too hard to
try to game plan years
and study the things you had to study to
learn that offense that wasn't that was
in
how you're going to run that week so i
don't think he would let me do it
we had we had well i mean he gave me
full reign and control
you know the plays in it's up to you to
do something better
take advantage of something you're free
to do it as long as it works
did you get yelled at by bill walsh um
bill never building yell
he had this subtle way about him i i
still remember it as
uh one of the i threw an interception in
there in the end zone one time
and i used to go from the field right to
bill and then i'd go to the phones and
talk to coaches upstairs and
as i was coming off the field he had his
card with all the plays on in this hand
and
he was doing this thing right here like
this and i knew i was in trouble
and he got over there and i he said he
looked at me and i said what was that
i said um i think they call that an
interception
and he said he looked dead deadpan
try not to let that happen again i said
okay i promise i won't
that was my last time going straight to
bill from that point on i went to the
phones and then back to bill
but you didn't go rogue that often did
you that
like no he just he expected so much of
the quarterback position i didn't care
it was steve the bird me steve young
bono that matter i mean he expected
perfection out of that position of all
of them i mean he wanted everybody to
strive for that
perfect game but more so he wanted the
quarterback to be perfect
make great decisions never make a
mistake
it's not going to happen but you know in
in areas like that he had he was pretty
he was pretty demanding um when it comes
when it comes to the quarterback
he's uh joe montana joining us on behalf
of a new relationship announced today
between notre dame and guinness
hey i can relate to both of those beer
and football
yeah you gotta love it i think what a
better combination right
two great traditions uh joining up to uh
you know enjoy and hopefully we're
getting ready to celebrate the
the coming back of football i'm not sure
it's gonna happen though but
um in the same time when you look at
them i think they both have
great great traditions behind them
looking to do the same things
commitments to making the world a better
place
and also trying to get people together
and enjoy it and
whether it's enjoying football or sports
we're going to do it
and with a nice glass a pint of
guinness and then we would have had what
was it navy and notre dame in dublin
this year
yep it got canceled there would have
been a lot of guinness being poured
right around there and that would have
been fun would love would love to sing
that so i don't know
hopefully it still happens but we'll see
what how it goes
i've i've been on the notre dame campus
on a weekend and
there wasn't much partying going on
there joe but when you were at notre
dame
did you party much there was no partying
at notre dame
at all okay
i'm gonna take you to your word joe you
would never lie to me
you never did that right it's one of the
biggest tailgates
that you know around college i know it
may not be as
epic as some of the big uh southern
schools that like to
say but i'll tell you what there's a lot
of
guinness being consumed in those parking
lots and
uh it was i mean it's fun to go back to
a game i think it's one of the most
exciting places to to go watch a
football game it's never been there
the tradition just you know leaks out of
everything as you walk around the campus
and
jennifer fell in love on on fridays the
band comes through the campus and
she just makes sure that we're there
every every time we go
um that we're there for that
that scene as they come through and play
uh the fight song through the campus
where would you have gone if it wasn't
notre dame
i i was i was torn between
if there's something that happened in
because i i was dreamt to go to notre
dame
and so as soon as they offered me i'd
cancel all the other schools but i had
probably
somewhere like michigan state or georgia
were on top top of the list at that time
um but
luckily for me i didn't have to make a
decision
so where did uh how do
you i know you didn't lose the super
bowl but you're jimmy garoppolo you got
to a super bowl
and you lost a super bowl so what advice
and in the off season the front office
kicked the tires on bringing in tom
brady here
well i think when you if you have a
chance to bring someone like brady
obviously as successful as he's been
bringing him back home i think
that would have been a great decision
for him
um what does it say about jimmy i don't
i don't
think it says much when you're looking
at a caliber person like like tom
coming in if that was the case but in in
the
side of it you know you have to jimmy
has to keep his head up
i mean he played his first full season
and got to a super bowl with him
and then played i thought played pretty
well i mean he made
he ended up making those guys i think
they tried to protect him too much in
the super bowl i'm not sure why
you know you missed a throw we all
missed throws yeah was that a big throw
he missed
that was a big throw but it's that
happens he needs to stay positive
and believe in himself i think the worst
thing you can do as a quarterback
i don't care if no one around you
believes in you the only person that has
to believe in you is you
and the minute you give that up
you won't be the starter any longer
you've got to fight and stay in there
and believe and
he has nothing to he has nothing to be
ashamed of i don't know
i mean every year there's somebody that
loses in the super bowl and every year
there's
a bunch of other teams that don't even
get there so hey
be proud of the season you had and just
think of hey
next time i have that film you know i'll
make it
and don't let negative things creep into
your head
i know we've had conversations before
about keeping
everybody happy on offense and you know
jerry rice you have the greatest
receiver of all time keeping him happy
and of course jerry was always open
that's why when i hear these stories
about antonio brown
and teams that should pick him up it's
hard to have that player as a chip on
her shoulder wants to prove everybody
wrong
and you gotta you gotta keep him happy
there
how how do you do that as a quarterback
where you
you got that guy who keeps telling you
i'm open and he wants to
he wants to prove everybody wrong
um you try to do the best that you can
to get him involved i mean there
jerry never complained if you could tell
on occasion if we hadn't told him the
past
there was something different going on
but he was quiet he never said much in
the huddle
and like you said every time he said
jerry were you open
yeah you know looking at you you've
watched the video there's three guys on
your house open though but they're all
like that they all want the ball
that's the kind of guy though you want
right you want someone who wants the
ball
but he can't have it all the time right
to be i mean
i think team started figuring out how to
play the 49ers
was to keep jerry from getting behind
everybody and putting somebody there and
on him and then somebody behind him
telling him get down the field on you
and that makes you have to go to the
other side now we were fortunate though
but we had john taylor you know and i
feel bad for john because
john was if he had asked for a trade and
gone somewhere else he'd have been jerry
rice
he was he was a freak of nature never
said a word though
i mean we'd run double routes i mean i
felt so bad for him
we'd run like we don't run double routes
much anyway we'd run like double
comebacks with deep
25 yard outs and uh john taylor john
taylor
jerry look up there you look over there
and john taylor's wide open
and going sorry but
is this story true though when you threw
the touchdown pass to john taylor to win
the super bowl against the bengals was
jerry rice the the decoy
yeah yeah the the the gist of the route
was in the inside
and what bill bill studied well most
coaches do this but they'll study in
like
a certain motion or something and a
formation will put him into a certain
coverage
and that motion tended to kick them into
two deep safeties
and john taylor has a re-route so he has
if there's a single safety he hooks to
the outside at this
split safety takes a little nod out and
then splits the safeties trying to stay
closest to the one
by him and jerry's just really
dressing on the cake to get him the end
of that coverage yeah how did jerry feel
about being a decoy in the super bowl
where john taylor
catches the game-winning touchdown
i'm sure he wanted the ball to i'm sure
he was open over there on the side
but uh you know he's no matter much
how much he wanted the ball he still was
a great team player you know
he was so happy for john you know
obviously
he was the um the mvp yeah so
it didn't really matter and uh you know
one other item we of course
lost our good buddy dwight clark so he
took with him to the grave
the secret of were you really trying to
throw the ball away
against the dallas cowboys joe i guess
we're never gonna know
if you or everson walls maybe uh
if you were really trying to throw that
ball away
well i was trying to throw over a six
foot eight guy so
so that was ed two tall jones is in your
face
and so i had i thought i had it soft
enough
up there and when i let it go i thought
it was
arm's length above his head and
everybody i heard him scream
i forgot okay touchdown no big deal and
our equipment manager when we got onto
the sideline
he said to me boy your buddy saved your
ass that time
what are you talking about he goes he
jumped out of this
he jumped out of the stadium to catch
that pass i'm going chico he's white he
can't choke
but uh yeah i mean he made a great catch
where is that ball
where's that ball i think dwight had
well dwight had it
oh yeah there's always a everybody says
they have it so i'm not sure for sure
where it is but
um yeah it's it was uh
he made a great catch and then we we
never thought we'd ever we never threw
the ball to dwight on that play we ran
that play a million times
during the year and bill made his
weirdest thing as bill made us practice
it in
in training camp to throw that to him we
both thought he was crazy
well we never thought to him you're
supposed to be done set a pick and
just throw the ball with a guy coming
off the pick that's it's simple
but little did we know how important it
would be later
also yeah hey great to talk to you
joe is going to be featured in uh
guinness tv spots social media other
promotional activities
in the months ahead and uh hopefully
we'll we'll get a chance to have a beer
together there joe it's great to see you
i think
i think there's some coming your way oh
yeah
so hopefully you buried the lead you
buried the lead joe we're getting
we're getting guinness all right yeah
yeah it's coming your directions
yeah i'm in both sides so happy to be a
part of this
this partnership and always great to
talk to you thank you buddy and i just
checking though
when you ran out of here are you okay
just want to make you know because i
have
my daughter left some diapers here in
case if you need one
wow i know you're getting older wow
so just checking to make sure you're
okay wow
everything's still working yeah it is
sometimes it works too well joe
it works sometimes it works too often
where you got to get up and and go
so but thank you for looking out for me
uh my best to jennifer and uh thanks for
joining us
uh my pleasure always great to talk to
you that's joe montana